diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
berker monday cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
es ist uns eine große ehre dass wir
heute thomas suchen wir bei uns haben
wer ist der wissenschaftliche direktor
der nasa und das habe ich auch herr über
7 milliarden dollar er hat hier studiert
und dann beschlossen in die usa zu
ziehen
es ist eine kleine bühne für thomas
zurbuchen den forschungsdirektor der
amerikanischen raumfahrtbehörde nasa
zurbuchen gilt als eine der mächtigsten
wissenschaftler weltweit in seiner
wahlheimat amerika verkehr der mit den
höchsten politikern wie hier mit dem
vize präsidenten mike pence
bei der besichtigung einer weltraumsonde
[Musik]
auch in der schweiz kommen inzwischen
viele menschen zu seinen auftritten
[Musik]
eine bilderbuchkarriere die jedoch nicht
nach den vorstellungen seiner eltern
verlief
[Musik]
wenn der däne rune hier die promotion
spot soll sondern fragen die webseite
nicht nur seine karriere auch seine
biografie ist außergewöhnlich
aufgewachsen ist er im bergdorf heiligen
spende im berner oberland
sein vater war streng gläubiger prediger
in einer freikirche
sohn thomas hätte in seine fußstapfen
treten sollen aber der welt einen ganz
anderen weg er entschied sich für die
wissenschaft
[Musik]
ja hier bundesweit 264 bundesrat in der
12 natürlich bundesland auf der schweiz
für männer daheim also dass sie selber
20 jahre know hows im medienzentrum des
bundes findet unser erstes interview
statt das zu organisieren hatte wochen
gedauert
rund 20 personen kümmern sich umzubuchen
volle agenda
er ermöglicht faszinierende einblicke in
die weltraumforschung und das ist
gefragt auf amerikas wirklich drogen
natur funktioniert
das ist wichtig es ist schon unglaublich
schonung forscher
die chemnitzer von universum ist einer
von dyna-mess anfänger zum beispiel von
einer kenntnisstand ist der master
gebiert dem system oder andere panne
tormann ist ein um einen der bisher
aufregendsten momente seiner karriere
hatte zurbuchen am 26 november 2008 10
die landung der weltraumsonde insight
auf dem mars nach einer sechsmonatigen
reise und rund 300 millionen meilen
durch das weltall hat die raumsonde
inside ihr ziel erreicht den roten
planeten mars auf dem mars zu landen ist
immer schwierig über die hälfte der
versuche sind gescheitert
in einer halben stunde ist die landung
menschen weltweit schauen dem ereignis
live zu es gibt dann anordnen watch
partys sogar vor der küste von
madagaskar arbeit sollten die ganze
weite müssen wir den mut zeigen dass es
schwieriger ist es soweit ist sicher
dass man eigentlich dass es ein geschenk
sein
diese computeranimation zeigt wie die
landung aussehen könnte
[Musik]
nach dem eintritt in die marsatmosphäre
wird der roboter mithilfe von fallschirm
und brems raketen abgesenkt ein hoch
riskantes manöver richtig sieben minuten
so lange sind die steuerungsbefehle vom
kontrollzentrum bis zum lande modul
unterwegs immer noch dass obama so
sensibel dass er das gemacht
b
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da ist unglaublich viel schwieriger als
auch in allen dingen weil es nicht
geklappt hatte was hatte das kaiserpaar
kann man das macht es schwierig japan
sowie zwei neckar und weiter darum ist
leider ein ca wie viel geld hatte der
scp 100 millionen
probleme gibt es aber durchaus die
bodenbeschaffenheit auf dem mars ist
offenbar ganz anders als erwartet
ein instrument des endzeit roboters
genannt hemmen der maulwurf hat die
vermessungen bis zu fünf meter tief
gelangen sollen
bis jetzt hat man aber nur wenige
zentimeter geschafft endlich woher die
never vorstellungskraft 20 vom auto wird
von immer froh wenn miss ganz ganze auto
vom universum die vab nicht an die form
universal oder freefall vorstellen das
ist das für das gefühl von freiheit da
brauchen das gefühl von unendlichkeit
also wirklich wirklich locker also das
universum ist so viel mächtiger aus was
man ist auch vorstellbar dass gezogen
thomanek macht tom cruise dem himmels
telescope e elt quartett für tage immer
mehr konstanz grube sagt dusy galaxie
ugc vorne
herz du sicher von galaxien schwächen
würde also ist es so krawinkel vom
musiker vor galaxie zu suchen hat seit
jahren auch den amerikanischen pass in
der schweiz ist den meisten ruf zu
besuch
aber auch in dieser zeit ist der
astrophysiker fast ständig als nasa
missionen unterwegs zum beispiel in der
eth zürich hier bei einem auftritt
zusammen mit dem schweizer astronauten
claude nicollier
ein absolut salat das ist fast letzte
woche vor weihnachten und die
studierende haben und alles andere aber
dort kommen sie was sie wissen dass sie
ist ein unglaublicher kommunikator auch
hier ist die landung der marsmission
inside ein thema die eth hatte dafür an
geophysikalischen instrumenten
mitgearbeitet
menschen wie ihr können in guten teams
solche unglaublichen dinge schaffen
dinge die noch nie jemand erreicht hat
darum geht es so entdecken wir die neuen
ufer des kosmischen ozeans so gehen wir
ins all
immer tiefer auftritt in einem berner
gymnasium zurbuchen redet über den
nutzen von weiteren satelliten zb wenn
große wirbelstürme im anmarsch sind wie
hurricane florenz 2018 in den usa an der
uni bern wird die mit einem preis geehrt
eine ehemalige lehrerin und eines von
zwei wochen erfolgsrezepten das
networking
zum buch ins auftritte haben stets etwas
amerikanisches an sich auch dann wenn er
schweizerdeutsch spricht was macht er
jetzt eigentlich der forschungsdirektor
von nasa mahaney meeting vermachte
morgen bis 1
weil er die hauptstadt ja das machen was
ich wirklich machen jahrhunderts
emissionen der ist im frühjahr der
entwickler damit zuständig für die
wichtige entschädigt wird man so machen
und eine sehr umfassende entschädigung
formation kommt froh dass sie drehbücher
seien e-mails sich zwar langsam
mitbehandelt zur buchung für euch der
satz das geld nicht naja nicht also wozu
also absolut die hasseler mobilität
reuters nicht na das geht es nicht
angenommen hat sagt er
[Musik]
ein seltener besuch in seinem geburtsort
heiligen schwende hier ist dir den
einfachen verhältnissen aufgewachsen
wie ist es für sie hier oh ja ganz
sicher
er ist wer er ist weil er hier
aufgewachsen ist
ich denke bei aller liebe dass thomas
ein recht stuhrer mensch ist er ist
einer der sich durchsetzt und selten
nach er weiß wohin er will und wie er
dort ankommt
er gibt nicht auf ich denke das kommt
von der zeit als er noch hier oben lebte
unter manager die erste bis zu 4
die erste zeuge aus ich lag sie bei
rieneck es dass sie mit samsungs nach
umfragen abgeschlagen die buerger warum
er noch interessant
hier müssen wir einfach langweilig sie
hat sich mit vier jahren in der region
ihre motivation
absolut
[Musik]
schritt für schritt genau sie umgang mit
vielen grüßen tun aber es findet sich
ausruhen und amerika
[Musik]
es sei nicht so dass ich das gemacht
bevor ist passt ganz religiösen gab der
familienvater stefan paris gesagt es
wäre toll wenn ich habe mal eine distanz
von hier oben weg ging und einen weg als
wissenschaftler einschlug folgte auch
eine innere distanz zu seiner familie
auch die beziehung zu seinem bruder und
den beiden schwestern habe darunter
gelitten
nicht zuletzt weil thomas die religiöse
gemeinschaft seines vaters verließ und
den gottesdiensten den sogenannten
versammlungen fernblieb seine eltern
hätten seine karriere nicht aktiv
behindert aber diese oft nicht
verstanden
mit seinem vater sei es erst kurz vor
dessen tod zu einer aussöhnung gekommen
[Musik]
naja ich happy sagte er die generation
als sicher probleme machen kriegen das
wetter dabei oder net
das macht jetzt verloren also das
problem ist dass ihr zeit weg oder das
ist wissenschaftler wo es aufgehört
aussage auch zwei treffer vor
zwei koffer vom zentrum ist ein traum es
ist advent ist hier also zelle gehäuse
zeitung natürlich mein vater ist hier
gesehen und zweitens ein traum von der
ist für für lügner von einem moment das
negative sagt daten
das ganze ist 2000 auf meine art passt
aus positiv
die religiöse dimension
jetzt frage ich einfach was los ist ob
sie zweifel vorrang hat die zwei frauen
was ist seine gläubiger 70 easy mehr
vergeudet
zurbuchen zu besuch in seinem elternhaus
was ich es spätere fahrer seine mutter
leidet hier bereits an einer
krebserkrankung
[Musik]
ja eigentlich sehr vielen für 450 der
regel aber verändert
der positive 100 prozent meine kabine
gegangen ist 140 die hauptstärken sie
dem vater aus der wissenschaft die sie
auch gut aber das war die freiheit wenn
ich ein lied hängen sich bringen wenn
ich die wir uns anders das ist das das
wort
es macht also jörg krämer alsbach kaufen
ist ganz einfach einfach ein großes herz
für diesen fall ist
alfermann geschädigte auf den virus
software für diesen vier teams hätten
sagte er der ganze moment mit dem auto
vom apotheker in ganz europa
das sozialprestige dazu genug mit
schafft gezogen nach brunner denner geht
es verschafft ist einfach der metronom
und illegal
dann geht es immer dazu dass beckham am
zum probiert's nachts wegen seiner 34
erfolgreiches professor der universität
2 offen ist wo sie innovationschef so
ist porsche-chef ganz andere stefano
parisi stabil
wo man mehr alle ehre anders ist
die amerikanische raumfahrtbehörde nasa
ist allerdings oft auch ein spielball
der politik
präsident und sein vize nick baynes
geben ehrgeizige pläne vor
die vereinigten staaten sind seither
eine nation von ruhelosen pionieren die
immer danach streben neue horizonte zu
erreichen
vor 50 jahren war ein kleiner schritt
für einen menschen ein großer schritt
für die menschheit jetzt ist aber die
zeit für uns gekommen für den nächsten
großen schritt
wir wollen wieder amerikanische
astronauten auf den mond schicken
sie sollen auf der mond eine ständige
basis errichten und technologien
entwickeln die dann amerikaner zum mars
bringen und darüber hinaus astronauten
auf dem mond und mars eine riesige
herausforderung jeden kalifornien ist
das forschungszentrum der nasa für
marsmissionen über 5000 frauen und
männer arbeiten in diesem streng
bewachten territorium für die
raumfahrtbehörde ein neuer mars rover
soll im juli ins weltall geschickt
werden
eine heikle mission auch für
wissenschafts direktor zu buchen
darum fliegt die regelmäßig von
washington nach kalifornien in sterile
umgebung arbeiten die techniker am
nächsten mars-rover diese soll unter
anderem bodenproben nehmen und in
behälter abfüllen
diese behälter sollen eines tages von
einem raumschiff auf die erde
zurückgebracht werden
es wäre die erste rückreise vom mars
auch die europäer
china und die arabischen emirate wollen
dieses jahr marsmissionen starten
die zeit ist knapp klappt es im juli
nicht mit dem raketenstart muss man zwei
jahre warten
erst dann stehen erde und mars wieder so
günstig zueinander
betreffend der fehlenden teile ich habe
gehört dass die franzosen demnächst
liefern können
die auslieferung überprüfung in
frankreich findet am montag oder
dienstag statt
das system fürs absetzen des helikopters
sollte auch in ein paar wochen
eintreffen
gestern wurde mir gesagt dass diese
helikopter teile bereits geliefert
worden sind
warum sagen sie in ein paar wochen es
wurde von lockheed martin verschickt und
ist eingetroffen
aber die teilen ist noch ausgepackt
werden
man ist eure schicht um 2 uhr fand jetzt
gleich an
dann seid ihr fertig wer arbeiten von
halb drei bis abends um 23 uhr gut die
nächste schicht um 7 uhr morgen geht es
dann weiter
das nimmt euren ganzen alltag ein ja das
tut
danke für eure arbeit das ist wirklich
cool
ich frage mich wozu braucht die
menschheit solche projekte paszek war
wurde der roboter tour nach was aber
sofern man die frage beantworten warum
man etwas wie jetzt beantwortet usinger
vorjahr auf jetzt beantragen frage ist
warum trainer von einer fragen kommt mit
penne mit einer maschine nicht die ganze
frauen maschine nach afrika auf der
oberfläche von marseille hat ein
wichtiger fragen von menschen die zum
beispiel klima und immer man das modul
mittels absoluten beträge der mission
autonomie mario insbesondere das wasser
auf der oberfläche der machen seines
standorts etwas ganz anderes machen
[Musik]
umstritten ist die frage ob man wirklich
menschen auf den mars schicken soll
stand jetzt würde das mehrere hundert
milliarden franken kosten
das dürfte also noch jahre dauern
immerhin der neue rovers und
erkenntnisse darüber liefern welche
gefahren und gesundheitsrisiken es auf
dem mars für menschen gibt
[Musik]
ein nobles wohngebiet im bundesstaat
virginia
hier wohnen die zurbuchen sowie viele
hohe beamte die im nahe gelegenen
washington dc arbeiten zur buchens frau
erin ist lehrerin und musiker den sie
haben zwei kinder
lukas und maria thomas einfordern der
vater sagt seine frau über den sehr gut
die fragen stellen
ich hoffe aber sie ja also das
leistungsniveau nicht ein bewegendes er
ist ja was ist denn das mauer erschlagen
tatsache ist es nicht aber die us-märkte
ist es mit nachmachen so einfach macht
[Musik]
er hat gerade die staatsmeisterschaften
gewonnen
im rudern ja schade haben wir das nicht
filmen können es war so toll ihn
gewinnen zu sehen ist zu kräftig dafür
zu suchen so lukas und tochter maria
waren nicht sehr begeistert über unsere
filmaufnahmen
sie tun sich noch etwas schwer damit
dass ihr vater inzwischen zur prominenz
gehört aber sie wollen unabhängig sein
maria hat doch einmal ein
ausgezeichnetes wissenschafts video
gemacht zum thema schwarze löcher und
thomas wollte es auf seinem
twitter-account veröffentlichen
maria sagt der auf keinen fall
sie wollte nicht dass ihr video in
irgendeiner art und weise einen bezug zu
ihrem vater hatte und du hattest das
akzeptiert die kinder wohnen das beste
erreichen aber sie wollen es alleine der
job bringt es mit sich dass ihr vater
auch an sonntagen ans geschäft denken
muss zum beispiel präsident trump wie
dreimal auf twitter aktiv ist und damit
verwirrung stiftet so auch in
zusammenhang mit der geplanten mond
mission
[Musik]
ein täter hat gestern unser leben
verändert der tag war viel aufregender
als irgend jemand gedacht hätte mit all
dem geld das wir ausgeben sollte die
nasa nicht darüber sprechen wieder zum
mond zu gehen das haben wir vor 50
jahren gemacht sie sollte sich auf
größere dinge fokussieren
zum beispiel auf den mast ragte auf
einmal wie es so wir wieder auf den mond
man solle doch zu marx der präsident hat
diesen tweet verschickt und ich war
gerade in einem meeting und alle fragen
was tun wir jetzt
in solchen fällen liegt es oft an thomas
zurbuchen im amerikanischen parlament
für klarheit zu sorgen und zu erklären
für was genau die amerikanischen
steuerzahlenden der nase jährlich über
20 milliarden franken gewesen
ein paar tage nach tram street ist so
buchen bei einer subkommission des
kongresses vorgeladen
guten morgen bevor wir beginnen möchte
ich sagen dass es für mich wirklich eine
freude wird eine ehre ist diese
subkommission zu leiten
unsere investitionen im alle und in die
raumfahrt sind katalysatoren für
wachstum entdeckungen und innovation in
amerika aber wir müssen aufpassen dass
die nasa auch beim kostenmanagement so
innovativ ist wie bei den
wissenschaftlichen entdeckung
es freut mich heute hier aus zu sagen
wir wollen bis ins jahr 2024 menschen
auf den mond schicken und von dort bis
2028 eine nachhaltige präsenz aufbauen
damit schaffen wir die voraussetzungen
für die erforschung des planeten mars
durch menschen vor ort das ultimative
ziel dieses nasa programms danke
vorsitzende und ein großes texas
willkommen für unsere experten könnten
sie mir erklären warum wir zuerst auf
den mond gehen müssen um schneller auf
den mars zu kommen
das ist eine wichtige frage diese
stellen
es gibt einen fundamentalen unterschied
ob man noch in der erdumlaufbahn ist
oder im weltall
das hat zu tun mit der strahlung dort
draußen man muss für längere zeit in
diesem strahlungs umfeld leben können
wenn man auf den mars will
und genau das können wir auf der
oberfläche des mondes üben
unser ultimatives ziel ist von den
natürlichen ressourcen auf dem mond und
der mars leben zu können was er zum
beispiel ressourcen die eines tages
vielleicht von firmen abgebaut werden
können
das gäbe neue geschäftsmodelle das ist
positiv wir würden nicht in den
vereinigten staaten seien dem land das
wir lieben wenn die menschen vor uns
nicht auch so gedacht
nein
[Musik]
bei diesem raketenstart in florida
anfang mai hätte auch thomas zurbuchen
mit vor ort sein sollen und wir mit ihm
aber das schicksal wollte es anders und
wir trafen uns stattdessen wieder in
heiligen schwende es war ein trauriger
tag
[Musik]
meine ich würde jetzt ja ja ja ja ich
weiß das sehr sehr klug lobte das jetzt
mit dem vater im himmel als gesichert
dass sie das gewissen hoffe so groß dass
sie dachte er es nennt
die meisten dieser frage beantwortet der
grundtarif einfach heißt das oft rentner
sind da natürlich wäre das mal nicht
natur gedanke es geht der gott aber also
die seite dass auch er hat die erfahrung
so behauptet es gebe keine zweifel also
es ist ein schlechter senden akzeptiere
dass sie das adobe 100 prozentig sicher
das für sie richtige passiert deutscher
sie aber weg sein vater ist genau das
was ist mit dem vater
ich hoffe dass es genauso
am anfang
ich habe daher für eine partie gesperrt
[Musik]
zerstörter heute muss ich sogar größer
der schutz natürlicher offiziell der 70
ja das ist genial braucht der bürger
aber wer schaut dabei auch das doppelt
beschäftigt ohne doppel tmn eine
hitzeperiode für milliarden euro gehen
die dahin geschickt und so weiter das
ist die top und auch mal stolz auf das
was wir hier haben
anders als gedruckt vorliegt tollen job
machen kontakte morgen früh zum lager
verhilft dass sie nach wie vor lieber
genau briefversand irgendwie soll die
socceroos gegen die schweiz mit 2 0
das visuelle sich nennt nach entnahme
also dass hier die thomas zurbuchen
schule
[Musik]
es ist sommer in werden zu buchen ist
für mehrere vorträge in seine ehemalige
ohne gekommen
er trifft dabei auf seinen bruder lukas
chefgärtner in bern
er wohnt noch im elternhaus in heiligen
schwende thomas zu buchen ist der mann
des tages in den beiden zeitungen
wie schätzt dass für diversität aus
familiärer als ruhig aber geschafft
diese garantie zurück zog sich die
brüder rené und und sich damit als
familien die geschichte
eigentlich große orientierte ende
beendete zurückkaufen was habe ich es
noch nicht
handball ist dass das konnten die
geschichten von früher irgendwo am rand
ist dass guter service ist
als skandal zb die eltern selber flora
kurzporträt mutter großer zieht weiß das
sag ich mal zwickt von uns
wenn es gar nichts nichts mit seiner
familie gruppe
weniger machen danke natürlich wurde
nicht über die ihre freikirche und das
familienleben möchte lukas zurbuchen
lieber nicht vor der kamera treten auf
seine beiden schwestern nicht
[Musik]
also nicht einfach an der wand das ist
ja immer kopf dass es ja das gute so
dass die kritik der macht ist es okay
ist nach amerika gegangen
plötzlich ist italiens ex meister tv
oder gar nix das ist nach ja seine
ältere schwester sagte mir sie würde
dafür beten dass thomas wieder den weg
zurück in die religiöse gemeinschaft
findet am letzten vortrag ihres bruders
im werden ist sie auch dabei der kamera
zu uns gekommen
beim mini mit
die blutlüge um mitternacht
im öffentlich dem namen vom bund ganz
herzlich zu dem boden dem sprach und
david live stream
und wer weiß vielleicht sogar das paar
bekannt
dazu wird josef stand by me to go was
mit menschen oder vorher mit dem mond
mit morgen destinationen jungen magier
der vorderste reihe ohne frage also
hätte mehr gibt wenig astronauten helfen
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von br genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
der camembert cremiger genuss seit 1902